most hosts come on the show to promote
something like when they asked me to
host
i said i'd love to but i have this new
show called barry on hbo premiering
march 25th
is that a conflict of interest and they
said no
it helps
i know that seems like a lot for tv
this woman raised me and changed my
diapers lucky lady
hey you're a step up his last steady
girl was a blow up doll
come on easy bro hey just kidding hey
feliz navidad huh
[Applause]
you know when someone does an impression
of a celebrity and then the real
celebrity sneaks up behind them like tap
tap i just caught you
that's planned
i didn't know that
you know what you should be ashamed of
yourselves
one thing i learned after leaving the
show was that first commercial after the
monologue the ones we're in
the ones that are like it's toothpaste
it's toothpaste with crack in it
those are fake
i know that i can't buy this product
[Laughter]
in the film disturbia
peace
if you're looking for a place to relax
with an old lady look no further
new york's hottest club is spicy
opened in 2017 on the upper east side of
a dumpster
polishing our helmets
you know uh you should see how shiny he
gets it
what is a human kite it's that thing
where you tie a string to a [ __ ]
and a windbreaker and then run through a
field
that's fun all right well look
um you guys i'm really i'm really
really i'm really happy for you both i'm
happy for you both
get back on sam vicente take it to the
ten then switch to the fourth
four and five north let's down
the line
this place has everything asbestos
lupus the magazines at supercuts
dan cortes
[Applause]
a doorman who always high-fives children
of divorce
oh you're hurting my arm who's gonna
believe you
what's a human roomba it's that thing of
when you put a [ __ ] on a skateboard
[ __ ] on a skateboard and it slides
slides around on your floor eating
garbage
[Applause]
okay uh i'm here not not now what do i
do look at him angrily
and say what are you doing
wait you're just gonna walk in here and
this place has everything
kiwis spud webs
[Applause]
no no come on
[Music]
[Applause]
you can lose yourself on the dance floor
surrounded by 12 dancing jupiters
stupids jewish cupids
cool they just want you to meet someone
nice and settle down yeah
i'm just trying to lighten the mood
[Music]
like human suitcases
what is a human suitcase it's a thing of
when a [ __ ]
on roller skates wears all of your
clothes and then you pull them through
an
airport step five step
on stefan
i'm having a good time this guy ain't so
bad
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do you know that billy joel song the
stranger
yeah well it's when you sit on billy
joel's hand
until it's numb and then you rub
yourself with it
[Applause]
hola me
let me do your taxes oh what do we have
here i'm herman k
and i want to touch your hawaiian
boobies this place has
everything young popes old popes
roman j is
oh
two little people
crouch on the bathroom floor and you put
your feet on their heads
[Applause]
why don't you sit on my face
i guess we only need two seats now but
all the proceeds go to charity oh which
charity
flat flaccid outreach group doctors
without boners